he's right now
hey there editor Alexa ray Korea
standing in for reviewer Miguel
concepción to tell you about Dragon
Quest heroes the world trees whoa and
the blight below no video game character
conveys endearment and sadism in a
single expression as well as the blue
slimes in Dragon Quest Heroes these
iconic teardrop shaped blobs have never
looked more adorable and homicidal which
is what makes killing them and mass one
of this game's greatest pleasures it's
one of its many delights athlete
delivered by a collaboration that is one
part dynasty Warriors one part Dragon
Quest as a contrast to all the
dimension-hopping that made up much of
last year's Hyrule warriors this Dragon
Quest spin-off takes the reverse
approach instead of protagonist jumping
to various older worlds like an older
Dragon Quest games adventurers from
those games come into the new world
established in Dragon Quest heroes
welcoming these otherworldly guests is a
new foursome comprising of two Co
protagonists whose default names are
Aurora and lucious the boisterous King
Doric and a skilled inventor named isla
dragon quest has always excelled in
defying traditional fantasy RPG party
formations and archetypes and this new
team could easily carry a mainline
Dragon Quest installment this mingling
of heroes from other worlds helps
distract from the story's laughably
generic premise of light versus dark the
story starts off on an uncommon ly
cheerful note even by Dragon Quest
standards where humans and monsters are
happily coexisting due to a spell by a
dark wizard named Velasco the monsters
are suddenly reminded that they're
supposed to hate humans the ensuing
chaos and unrest gives the game's heroes
more than enough to deal with let alone
reason to investigate why their non
human friends suddenly turned on them
the bread and butter of the Dynasty
Warriors franchise and many of its
spin-offs has been the map wide
territorial of tug of war where you and
your armies raced against the opposing
military in conquering land one path
at a time in Dragon Quest Heroes it's
not a tug of war so much as it is an
exercise in permanently putting out
fires namely enemy spawn points called
laws it's a veritable rush to run from
law to MA while weeding past the
opposition leaving the minions to the
rest of your team Dragon Quest heroes
sticks to the series hack and slash
gameplay which means that it benefits
from a battle system that has taken 15
prolific years to mature it's come a
long way from the outdated and stiff
controls of Dynasty Warriors 2 from deft
midair attacks too deadly for hit combos
every hero's repertoire is more than
adequate you might wish for the depth
and exactness of say Devil May Cry but
when time is of the essence in a single
sword swing can take out half a dozen
skeletons
you don't need precision you certainly
don't eat it when your blade can summon
a screen clearing tornado what truly
sets Dragon Quest heroes apart from
other Warriors games is a monster minion
feature a given kill has the potential
to drop a metal version of that
respective monster with the metal you
can summon that monster as an ally aside
from the palpable drama of turning the
tide these minions create two games
within the game the first is knowing how
to best take advantage of a given
monster strengths given they don't
follow you throughout the battlefield
submitting a monster the moment you get
its metal isn't necessarily the best
move sometimes it's better to save them
in anticipation of harder enemies at the
latter half of a mission the second game
involves the strategic placement of
monsters along a crowded path of enemies
this creates countless opportunities for
you guessed it tower defense game play
it's satisfying to have a squad of
self-sufficient teammates human or
otherwise who can limit the flow of
gargoyles goodie bags and haka sources
while you're off focusing on enemy
portals as you're multitasking in battle
you'd be surprised how gratifying it is
to check on your monsters later on to
find that they have everything under
control
against equally large foes and even if
you have more pressing matters to attend
to
no one would blame you for briefly
jumping into this orgy of destruction
its sheer bedlam when you can get these
larger creatures to fill up your screen
Dragon Quest heroes the world trees whoa
in the blight below affords every lover
of the franchise the rare opportunity to
cause genital destruction but the kind
of efficiency you cannot find in a
turn-based RPG these tens of thousands
of encounters plus the appearances by
the series many other heroes makes for
an essential experience for any Dragon
Quest fan even if you haven't played a
hack-and-slash er in ages you brought
this on yourselves
you